let's go back to the very start of all
this okay
why were you interested in even
indulging in this kind of plot against
to read at all you know I made a mistake
truthfully that's that's the long and
short of it and I think they banked on
the fact that my anger towards Dury
would surpass my moral compass and in
the end it didn't but you know at the
beginning I was like okay sure this is
what you know I'll help you guys let's
you know let's do this was it you had
this time between seasons to kind of sit
and stew and everything that went down
and there was something that happened
after the reunion where I was in the car
with Kyle and Lisa was in the car with
to read and we were all supposed to go
to dinner and then Lisa called and she
was like oh Marie refuses to go to
dinner if Teddy's there so it was like
little things like that that kept
happening did you ever have any
conversations directly with Lisa about
the dog situation or was it all through
the Vanderpump dogs it was all through
the Vanderpump dogs people there was no
doubt in my mind that this was Lisa and
Vanderpump dogs wanting me to do it and
I going down that road at all I should
have from the very GetGo said you know
what this doesn't involve me leave me
out of it but I didn't why would a Lisa
want to make her close friend to read
look bad I think she was angry about
things that dirt said to her last year
and I don't think she was over it and I
think that she wanted to punish treat
and you know I think that I was an easy
person to help do that for her we had
this text message sent to direct and the
timeline doesn't make sense how did you
know the text to read to read Teddy
knows
how did you know that Teddy knew I
didn't know at the time
teddy news okay you said you said that
they sent a text saying so that hurt
teddy know will we get resolution in a
clear answer on that I never got a clear
answer from Lisa Vanderpump because she
won't take ownership at anything and I
think what a lot of people been confused
about there's like when you're in the
Bahamas and you're saying I don't like
at that point I had already told the
women like I've been involved the point
was like I'm saying listen I'm involved
but this story all stemmed from
something she wanted out there I'm not
saying that I didn't make a huge mistake
here but you know they I was used to get
the point across the next kind of step
in this saga is the story getting out to
the press right and how all that plays
out
will we get firm answers on what exactly
happened with that no I mean obviously
regardless of who leaked it to the press
it was to get ahead of it so that the
viewers would already have their
opinions about derp eating the dog
before everybody started watching the
season that's clear who leaked it I
don't really care you know like but it
only benefits one person got it so and
it's a complicated thing because I know
you guys have contracts and stuff you
can't speak out about certain things
that are happening while you're filming
and all that so it's it was really
putting dur eat in a tough place cuz
yeah she can't stand up for herself when
I said like I was told a really
siliceous like fake story to get me
amped up and that wasn't true that
juried had locked that dog in her
basement and it hadn't seen the light of
day in months John Sesa tweeted
basically confirming that you were told
that story because he said we didn't
want all these details like sit there
come on truth is that story's changed
multiple times and by the time I had
even filmed at Vanderpump dogs I was
given a completely new story and so it's
like that's why it never became about
the dog it became about friendships
because it really wasn't about the dog
the dog was safe and where people are
like don't you love top of course I love
dogs I mean who doesn't love you
but you know you just can't keep
changing your story have you spoken to
John Blizzard since all of this happened
so there I spoke to him in the Bahamas
actually because I was very upset I was
like I can't believe I was used as a
pond and he agreed with me he's like how
did we become the bad people like how
did this become on us but then other
than that we haven't had any
communication until yesterday when he
tweeted again at me yes and shared more
text messages and I was like great you
just confirmed my point it seemed like
he was putting that text out there to
make you look like you were using van if
I'm to get your brother on the show but
in reality he exposed more information
about oh you just really cleared it up
that you guys started inviting me to
things all of these things started
happening after I was given that
information to give that friendship
illusion but let's be clear if it wasn't
a van der pump event or a Vanderpump
something we were never together right I
think it was pretty clear when you go on
when you've organized a meeting with
production to have a interview with your
brother on Vanderpump rules
you're pretty clear you're trying to get
him on the show right like I don't think
I was shady in that right when was the
last time you spoke to Lisa Vanderpump I
think it was Denise's wedding okay I
know that other women had spoken to her
since but I mean in her and I like I
said like we you know I can I can
coexist so it was fine when you saw that
footage of her in the car driving away
that city she's just like well I guess
were just agreed to coexist you should
be so lucky [ __ ] what did you think
that's her true colors that's always how
she thinks
you know she let she let her persona
down and show who she is if you were to
have Lisa in front of you today what
would you say to her I don't really have
anything to say I'm not pushing to build
any relationship with her I'm fine to be
at the same room as her I'm fine if the
girls each of their relationships are
their own so they should do what they
want but I I'm really good is the door
open for reconciliation or I don't think
it's possible for reconciliation without
truth without being honest without being
vulnerable we know sooner rather than
later she pulled away from the group
what was the big moment that led to that
was it that fight with Kyle
Villa Rosa when Kyle came back to the
group and told you guys what had
happened at Villa Rosa what did you
think there's no need for that level of
anger and for your husband to do that
and to not stop your husband to me
that's really telling the next
opportunity you guys might have to see
Vanderpump is at the reunion do you
think she will show up I don't know
probably I don't I I really have no idea
Lisa's fans are kind of fiercely
protective of her to put it lightly on
social media how are you handling those
attacks some stuff is I think it's
taking it too far but to go on
somebody's page and attack them to the
level of like you're disgusting ugly
vile human being and I hope your kids
are bullied at school that's like okay
let's let's take a little breath eating
like I'm still a real human being and
this is not necessary well more
information come out in the coming weeks
that might change some of those fans
minds I don't think so
on the flip side there are people who
are saying teddy is finally the one who
has been able to have the group see
Vanderpump's true colors like many women
have come in and tried it had Brandi do
it we've had Eileen do it it's not
necessarily me if something continues to
happen over and over and over and over
again you can only sit there and watch
it so many times or you can only turn a
blind eye to something so many times
until it's really tiresome yeah and it
becomes exhausting and the level that
somebody will go to and to take somebody
else down while pretending to be a hero
it really it's time-consuming some fans
feel like this is taking al Kapone down
on tax charges like this dog thing feels
a little compared to other things she's
done in the past she's like nobody
needed some grand apology it could have
been like listen I just let things get
too far I was upset right that's really
all it would have taken I mean we're
we're a forgiving Bunch
we all like we see what the fans are
saying and yes of course it would have
made more sense for jury to take the dog
originally back to Vanderpump dogs
but if that was the case when when Jerry
called Lisa and said hey I gave the dog
away to this woman why that day didn't
Lisa say go pick that dog up and bring
it to back to Vanderpump roads it makes
no sense if she does make it to the
reunion is there a place in this group
for her moving forward of course I mean
this is this is the thing and I think
that the women have gotten that gone
through a lot worse a lot more I mean
everybody's in a place where we figure
it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]